>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
THERE WAS A HORRIFYING AMOUNT OF
VIOLENCE IN THE UNITED STATES
OVER THE WEEKEND, AS
INCREASINGLY THERE IS.
OVER JUST TWO DAYS AT LEAST 104
AMERICANS WERE SHOT TO DEATH AND
MAJOR AMERICA CITIES, THAT IS A
LOT.
FOR PERSPECTIVE, ON THE SINGLE
DEADLIEST DAY OF THE IRAQ WAR IN
JANUARY OF 2005, A TOTAL OF 37
AMERICANS DIED.
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN OUR CITIES
RIGHT NOW LOOKS A LOT LIKE A
WAR, EVEN IF WE RARELY
ACKNOWLEDGE IT.
DALLAS, MILWAUKEE, PHILADELPHIA,
MANY OTHER METRO AREAS.
IN ST. LOUIS, 15 PEOPLE WERE
SHOT.
IN CHICAGO, 33 WORK ON DOWNED,
FIVE OF THOSE DIED.
IN LAGUNA WOODS CALIFORNIA,
CHINESE IMMIGRANTS FROM
LAS VEGAS WALKED INTO A
PRESBYTERIAN CHURCH AND SHUT SIX
ELDERLY TAIWANESE PARISHIONERS.
AND OF COURSE, MOST FAMOUSLY OF
ALL, ON SATURDAY AFTERNOON, A
TEENAGER AND A MOCK MILITARY
UNIFORM WALKED INTO A
GROCERY STORE AND BUFFALO AND
SHOT MORE THAN A DOZEN STRANGERS
WITH A RIFLE.
WHAT YOU PROBABLY HAVEN'T SEEN
OUR DETAILS ABOUT ANY OF THE TEN
AMERICANS WHO WERE MURDERED IN
THAT STORE AND BUFFALO PRETTY
YOU MAY NOT EVEN KNOW THEIR
NAMES.
MOST OF THEM WERE BLACK, YOU
KNOW THAT.
BE ON THE WAY THEY LOOKED, NOT A
LOT HAS BEEN REPORTED ABOUT
THEM.
BECAUSE THE COVERAGE HASN'T BEEN
ABOUT THEM.
NOR IN FACT HASN'T REALLY BEEN
ABOUT THE GUNMAN, THE
18-YEAR-OLD CALLED PEYTON
GENDRON.
HE WAS MENTALLY ILL, EVERYONE
AROUND KNEW THAT.
LESS THAN A YEAR AGO, HE WAS
COMMITTED TO A MENTAL HOSPITAL
AFTER THREATENING TO MURDER HIS
CLASSMATES AT A SCHOOL
GRADUATION CEREMONY.
ON SATURDAY, HE LEFT A 180 PAGE
LETTER THAT HE SAID WOULD
EXPLAIN HIS MOTIVES.
YOU'VE PROBABLY HEARD THIS
DOCUMENT DESCRIBED AS A RACIST
MANIFESTO.
THAT IS NOT QUITE RIGHT.
IT IS DEFINITELY RACIST,
BITTERLY SO.
HE REDUCES PEOPLE TO THEIR SKIN
COLOR, THAT IS THE ESSENCE OF
HER RACISM AND IT'S IMMORAL.
WHAT HE WROTE DOES NOT ADD UP TO
A MANIFESTO.
IT IS NOT A BLUEPRINT FOR NEW
POLITICAL MOVEMENT.
ANYONE WHO CLAIMS THAT IT IS IS
IN LINE OR HASN'T IT.
INSTEAD, HIS LETTER IS A RAPIDLY
BLESSED EACH OF SLOGANS AND
INTERNET MEMES, SOME OF WHICH
FLATLY CONTRADICT ONE ANOTHER.
THE DOCUMENT IS NOT RECOGNIZABLY
LEFT-WING OR RIGHT-WING.
IT'S NOT POLITICAL AT ALL.
THE DOCUMENT IS CRAZY.
IT'S THE PRODUCT OF A DISEASED
AND ORGANIZED MIND.
PART OF SOME GLOBAL CONSPIRACY
AGAINST HIM.
DISJOINTED, IRRATIONAL,
PARANOID.
THAT IS TRUE, NOT THAT IT MAKES
THE ATROCITIES HE COMMITTED
EASIER TO BEAR.
HE WOULDN'T CARE WHERE THE
KILLER DID IT OR WE DID IT FOR.
THE TRUTH ABOUT PEYTON GENDRON
DOES TELL YOU A LOT ABOUT THE
RUTHLESSNESS AND DISHONESTY OF
OUR POLITICAL LEADERSHIP.
WITHIN MINUTES OF SATURDAY
SHOOTING BEFORE ELOPED BODIES
HAD EVEN BEEN IDENTIFIED BY THE
LOVED ONES, THEY BEGAN A COORDIE
CAMPAIGN TO BLAME IT ON THEIR
POLITICAL OPPONENT.
THEY DID IT, THEY SAID
IMMEDIATELY.
PEYTON GENDRON WAS THE HEIR TO
DONALD TRUMP, THEY TOLD US.
AND FOR THAT REASON, IT FOLLOWS
LOGICALLY, WE MUST SUSPEND THE
FIRST AMENDMENT.
THAT'S HARDLY AN EXAGGERATION OF
WHAT THEY ARE SAYING.
HERE'S A SELECTION FROM
YESTERDAY'S SUNDAY SHOWS.
>> SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAVE NOT DONE
ENOUGH TO MONITOR, TO BAN, TO
RESTRICT, AND TO LIMIT HATE
SPEECH ON THEIR SITES.
HATE SPEECH IS NOT FREEDOM OF
SPEECH.
>> AS YOU KNOW, THE
FIRST AMENDMENT DOES NOT PROTECT
HATE SPEECH.
SPEAK I WILL PROTECT THE FIRST
MOMENT ANY DAY OF THE WEEK, BUT
YOU DON'T PROTECT HATE SPEECH.
YOU DON'T PROTECT INCENDIARY
SPEECH.
YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO SCREAM
FIRE IN A CROWDED THEATER.
THERE ARE LIMITATIONS ON SPEECH.
>> Tucker: WHAT IS HATE
SPEECH?
SPEECH THAT OUR LEADERS HATE.
BECAUSE OF MENTALLY ILL TEENAGER
MURDERED STRANGERS, YOU CANNOT
BE ALLOWED TO EXPRESS YOUR
POLITICAL VIEWS OUT LOUD.
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE TELLING
YOU, THAT IS WHAT THEY WANTED TO
TELL YOU FOR A LONG TIME, BUT
SATURDAY'S MASSACRE GIVES THE
PRETAX AND JUSTIFICATION.
YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF, WHO
BEHAVES LIKE THAT?
WHAT SORT OF PERSON USES MASS
MURDER AS AN EXCUSE TO GIVE A
CAMPAIGN SPEECH OR SEES MORE
POLITICAL POWER?
WE WILL FIND OUT TOMORROW WHEN
JOE BIDEN TRAVELED TO THE SCENE
OF THIS ATROCITY AND BUFFALO TO
SPEAK TO THE COUNTRY.
EVEN SEEN AN ADVANCE COPY OF HIS
REMARKS, BUT YOU CAN GUESS.
IT APPEARS TO BE THE LOWEST
EVER, LOWER THAN DONALD TRUMP'S
PRAYER THAT IS A DISASTER FOR
HIS PARTY.
THEY WILL SUFFER FOR THIS IN THE
ELECTION.
BIDEN STILL IS TIME TO CHANGE
COURSE AND FIX IT.
HE COULD TRY TO IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF VOTERS WHO ARE
DISSATISFIED WITH THEM.
THAT IS WHAT POLITICIANS
TYPICALLY DO AND THEY ARE DOWN.
THEY LISTEN TO THE PEOPLE WHO
MIGHT REELECT THEM.
BIDEN DOESN'T PLAN TO DO THAT,
AND WE KNOW FOR A FACT BECAUSE
POLITICO HAS REPORTED IT.
BIDEN IS TAKEN TO TELLING HIS
AID HE NO LONGER RECOGNIZES THE
G.O.P., WHICH HE NOW VIEWS AS AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO THE
NATION'S DEMOCRACY.
PEOPLE WHO DISAGREE WITH
JOE BIDEN ACCORDING TO JOE BIDEN
ARE NOW "AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT
TO THE NATION LIKE AL QAEDA OR
CLIMATE CHANGE.
I THOUGHT THAT BY DEFINITION IS
SO PROFOUND THAT WE MUST DECLARE
WAR UPON IT IN ORDER TO SURVIVE.
THIS THREAT THAT BIDEN IS
REFERRING TO IS YOU.
HE IS TALKING ABOUT HIS FELLOW
AMERICANS.
NO PRESIDENT HAS EVER SPOKEN
LIKE THIS COME EVER.
JOE BIDEN DOES IT REGULARLY AND
HE CERTAIN TO DO IT AGAIN
TOMORROW.
THE MOST PAINFUL OF ALL, BIDEN
IS LIKELY TO USE RACIAL WOUNDS
IN ORDER TO MAKE HIS POINT.
THERE IS NO BEHAVIOR WORSE THAN
THIS.
ALWAYS POLITICS IS BAD, NO
MATTER WHAT FLAVOR THOSE
POLITICS HAPPEN TO BE.
NO RACE POLITICS IS BETTER THAN
ANY OTHER.
ALL OF IT IS POISON.
WHERE IS POLITICS SUBDUED THE
INDIVIDUAL INTO THE GROUP.
IT ERASES PEOPLE, IT DEHUMANIZES
THEM.
ELEVATES APPEARANCE OVER
INITIATIVE AND DECENCY AND ALL
THE OTHER GOD-GIVEN QUALITIES
THAT MAKES EVERY PERSON OF EVERY
COLOR UNIQUE, YET MORALLY EQUAL
TO EVERY OTHER PERSON.
AND ABOVE ALL, RACE POLITICS
ALWAYS MAKES US HATE EACH OTHER.
AND ALWAYS IN A VERY PREDICTABLE
WAY.
SO LET'S SAY YOU WERE TO MAKE A
IDENTITY POLITICS MANDATORY.
HOW COULD YOU BE SURPRISED WHEN
THAT LEADS TO WEIGHT IDENTITY
POLITICS.
YOU COULD NOT BE SURPRISED.
YOU DID IT AND IT WAS ALWAYS
GOING TO HAPPEN.
AND THEN WHAT HAPPENS NEXT?
NOTHING GOOD.
RACE POLITICS IS A SIN, RACE
POLITICS ALWAYS LEADS TO
VIOLENCE AND DEATH.
THEY LEARNED THAT IN RWANDA IN
1984.
KILLED 800,000 PEOPLE.
AND RESPONSE TO THOSE HORRORS
THAT WERE SOMETHING WE MIGHT
LEARN FROM.
THEY MOVED TO THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION FROM WHEN JOE BIDEN IS
CURRENTLY TAKING THE
UNITED STATES.
GO TO ETHNICITY HAS BEEN
STRIPPED OUT OF SCHOOLBOOKS AND
ROPED OFF GOVERNMENT IDENTITY
CARDS AND THE NEWSPAPERS AND
RADIO STATIONS STEER CLEAR AS
WELL."
THEY NOTIONALLY HEADED TO THE
KITCHEN, THE RACIAL
IDENTIFICATION THAT SEEMED TO
LOOM SO LARGE TEN YEARS AGO AS
EXTREMISTS BEGIN THEIR MASS
KILLINGS.
THEY HAVE DEEMPHASIZED RACE AND
RWANDA, INTENTIONALLY AND
SYSTEMATICALLY.
RWANDAN CITIZENS ARE CITIZENS
FIRST, MEMBERS OF RACIAL OR
TRAVEL GROUPS, SECOND OR NOT AT
ALL.
THERE'VE BEEN NO MORE GENOCIDES
IN RWANDA, AND THAT COULD EASILY
BE THE PATH FORWARD FOR THIS
COUNTRY WAS ALSO PURE THERE WAS
ONLY ONE ANSWER TO RISING RACIAL
TENSION, AND THAT IS TO
DE-ESCALATE AND DO IT WE'VE
TRIED TO DO FOR HUNDREDS OF
YEARS, WHICH IS WORK FOR
MERITOCRACY AND TREAT PEOPLE AS
HUMAN BEINGS GREETED BY GOD
RATHER THAN HIS FACELESS MEMBERS
OF INTEREST GROUPS THAT MIGHT
BENEFIT SOME POLITICAL PARTY.
WE HAVE A MORAL DUTY TO DO THIS,
BECAUSE ALL PEOPLE HAVE EQUAL
MORAL VALUE, NO MATTER WHAT THEY
LOOK LIKE.
ALL LIVES MATTER, PERIOD.
IT IS THE DETERMINATION OF GOD.
MOST AMERICANS ALREADY BELIEVE
IT.
THEY'D LIKE TO SEE A RETURN TO
THE AMERICAN WAY OF LIFE.
THE AMERICAN WAY OF LIFE IS
MERITOCRACY.
JUDGE ME BY WHAT I DO, NOT BY
HOW I LOOK.
BY THE CONTENT OF MY CHARACTER,
NOT THE COLOR OF MY SKIN.
WE HAVE A MONUMENT ON THE MALL
TO THIS.
AND SUDDENLY EVERY VOICE AND
POWER IS LEADING US IN THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION.
AND EVERYBODY KNOWS THIS.
ONLY